this raises what i think is the most
uncomfortable question in all of kovid
for me i think maybe not quite but
when i look at what took place
over the course of the last two and a
half years
i am left with the following conundrum
it appears at first blush
to be
a case of massive incompetence
with respect to our response but when i
look in detail
i see that not only did we get
everything wrong but we got everything
backwards
if you did exactly the opposite of what
you were told in each and every case
you would have actually been doing
almost almost exactly what you should do
right you know they shut down the
beaches where should you have been oh
beach would have been a great place to
be if you'd stayed at the beach for the
whole pandemic you'd have been safe
right yeah
so you know
go home
and don't come back to get medical
treatment until you're already very sick
no you should treat from the first hint
that you have been in contact with covid
let alone
come down with it and going home is
exactly what's going to infect the
people who are trapped with you there
right so we can go down the list you
know
should you take should you count on a
repurposed drug
no stay away from those things they're
very dangerous what you should do is
take this uh immunosuppressive injection
that we call a vaccine
right
um
well
that's going to make matters worse right
the very nature of the vaccine is so
narrowly targeted that it actually
appears to have selected for a
proliferation of variants so if i go
down the list
we can identify 10 12 places where we
were told something very definitive
about what we should individually do and
what we should collectively do and each
one of them was the inverse of the right
answer now my contention
if it had been one decision then
incompetence could explain how you would
get the opposite of the right move
but if it's 10
12
different decisions and we got the
inverse of the right answer in every
case the probability that that happens
through incompetence is vanishingly
small yep
yeah i agree and i always think that
there was a there was
you know there was a motive behind it i
mean you know
we called conspiracy theorists for
mention the word you know mention the
words the great reset but
that was said right from the beginning
this is the opportunity for great
research do you know the first time i
heard that
expression i wasn't really well tuned
into this it's one of these these things
a lot of people would tuned into it well
before me and i wasn't right
the first time i was i i got really
frightened about this and realized this
is not what this is you know it's not a
coincidence it's not just a freak that
they're getting all these things wrong
was when i actually was invited onto a
panel
um
of
people who are involved supposedly with
the early coveted research because we'd
already right from the beginning we
published a paper where we'd found that
we'd already picked up on the fact that
the
uh the infection fatality rates were
exaggerated
right so we
a bayesian analysis we won i think we
were on first to publish
a paper peer review paper on that and so
i at that point that was not considered
to be too disrespectful it wasn't
considerably too out of sync with the
narrative
um so i got i was at that point invited
on to quite a few things sort of local
things in the uk i was on this um
this panel um with experts
and
every one of the experts on that plan
there was three others me and three
others and they all mentioned this great
reset they said they said this is they
all said it's fantastic because this was
actually when the the lockdown was
really hard after two months it was in
it was early june
2020 in the uk we've been locked down
solid for two over two months at that
point and they were saying it's
fantastic you know because this is great
for the environment this is this is
exactly what we need to they
specifically said for for climate change
and this is and they were saying things
this is the opportunity to completely
reset sight and they said yeah they said
klaus forms words this is the
opportunity of the great reset all the
other speakers said it i was shocked i
was completely
you know that's when i realized this is
you know i i said right i said from the
beginning or fairly soon after that
which i got a lot of flack for that
these covered lockdowns seem to me to be
a precursor for the climate lockdowns
and you know that's i think that it all
fits into that everything that was done
and is being done in the name of kovid
fits into that kind of like gender 2030
narrative
well i must say you know i'm open to
that possibility i'm not quite ready
i see a number of things that could
explain it
um you know
some of them
yeah
there's a conspiracy hypothesis here to
be certain but a mundane one right you
could get to an absolutely upside down
prescription
for
personal and public health
if
you decided for whatever reason that you
wanted to deliver the maximum number
of injections
uh you know and that could be for simple
reasons of economic profit right if you
decided that delivering injections was
the objective of the exercise then
everything else follows actually
um now i'm not saying that that is what
happened but i'm saying that as between
that hypothesis
and a
great reset that is driving these things
it's hard for me to sort between them
because they both predict the same thing
well i'll tell you why i i think that
the um i don't think it was the um
the vaccine narrative driving it then
i'll tell you why because
my view was that it actually wasn't a
conspiracy in the sense of you know a
small number of you know
um powerful men sort of deciding this
was the way we were going to go but the
fact that all the all of all the key
influences
right were brought in were already
bought into that idea that we need to do
something drastic we need drastic
changes to society right to tackle this
whole you know climate change uh you
know they call it a catastrophe or
emergency or whatever right they're so
bought into that
and that was indeed you know these other
people on the panel and many other
academics and people like if you think
about all the people who are advising
the governments right i mean take people
like neil fergus in the uk
neil ferguson susan mickey who made
major contributions on you know neil
ferguson you'll know obviously where
that he was the one with the the
ridiculous prescription predictions on
the number of deaths and susan mickey is
the the communist who uh was advising
the government on the on how to control
you know this behavioral control or all
that type of things you know she's now
been appointed as head of the world
health organization
science team anyway that's another thing
but all those people and throughout
government as well and i'm sure it was
the same us a bit different
at that time but certainly the uk was
people were taking their
uh seeing what was happening in the uk
and doing the same very much and
everywhere you looked with these same
the same clique of the elitist kind of
like academics
very very with this with this world view
that you need much greater control
over what people are doing in order to
confront confront this you know
potentially catastrophic as i would call
it this
climate change problem and so i think
that was that was driving it and the vax
and then you know the vaccines became
after that yeah okay that even more
convenient we can keep people you know
locked down you know for them it meant
they could keep people locked down even
further and longer until the vaccines
came around so those people certainly
weren't
into they had no interest in vaccines
from the sort of profit angle it was
simply it's it absolutely fitted their
their agenda for sort of continual
control and lockdown
well you know
so there are a number of topics we
should hit on here i should tell you i
do have real climate concerns i feel
certain that we are being misled with
respect you know the models are obvious
nonsense
but i do believe that there is a
potentially lethal problem to humanity
lurking in the form of frozen methane in
the arctic
and the problem is what we have is a
very polluted academic environment so we
can't really sort out how big a threat
it is and how close we are yeah to a
threshold so
um you know i i want to be careful that
we don't assume there is no problem just
because corrupt people are using uh the
threat to manipulate us which they
clearly are
um
so i don't know i don't know what you
think about that and i don't know
frankly how deeply you've delved into
the question of climate change
well the funny thing is um
i was uh
on i was actually i co-presented
uh a bbc documentary called climate
change by numbers in 2015 with hannah
fry and
sir david uh professor david
spiegelhalter and that's an interesting
experience in itself now because of
i they chose there was supposed to be
three mathematicians to look at the sort
of the numerical issues surrounding
right climate change and i was supposed
to be the one looking at the sort of
probabilistic statements and models
right and
uh and they chose us because we didn't
have we'd never done we'd never
supposedly never had any thoughts before
never commented on climate change i was
supposed to be independent but because
it was the bbc it wasn't at all
independent i mean i i came in fairly
open-minded and i left that program as a
complete skeptic because i saw the total
corruption sign it was the i mean i
can't i can't say it i can't speak about
everything because i'm actually i
actually you know had to i think sign
some
uh you know i was under some sort of
agreement where i can't
speak completely freely about what what
went on there and there's some things
which i think are quite you know quite
shocking but it was it was total it was
total bias it was a lot of stuff was you
know it was ridiculous okay but but this
actually strikes me as a perfect case
for a bayesian right you and i can both
look at the academic environment and say
well i know what's going to happen here
because you've got you've got
a group of people who are convinced that
we have an emergency and therefore
anything you publish that suggests the
emergency might not be as serious as we
think it might not be progressing as
rapidly as we think those people are
going to be shunned they'll be destroyed
that's going to leave you a intense
structural confirmation bias inside of
climate science right but what that
leaves you with
is no information about the reality it
does not leave you with evidence that
there's no problem
right and so i get that yeah
so my yeah
my approach has been
um
they keep telling me that you know we're
going to have an ice free arctic
so far we don't have an ice-free arctic
that tells me that they are ahead of the
curve right i was told that uh
kilimanjaro was going to be free of
glaciers they're retreating but it's not
free of glaciers likewise glacier
national park still has glaciers so all
of these things tell me that i am being
misled about the speed but then on the
other side
the fact i don't know of a challenge to
the idea that there is a tremendous
quantity of frozen methane in the arctic
and
the question is
at the point that we unleash
the
chemistry the atmospheric chemistry that
makes methane an intense
warming agent is straightforward doesn't
depend on a model
right and so the question is do we reach
a threshold where we release enough
methane
you release methane it causes a slight
warming that backs the
ice cap back a bit that releases more
methane so you get a positive feedback
and that question about whether or not
we reach a place with the frozen methane
in the arctic that the glacial retreat
that we can see that doesn't depend on
anybody's model predicts that we will
reach a point at which suddenly this
will no longer be even
controllable in principle by human
beings i worry about that and i worry
that the biggest threat to us is the
corrupt academic environment that makes
it impossible to address that question
objective
yeah no i i get what you're saying and
the problem is i i fundamentally don't
understand the notion that the humor
that that then of course i'm not
disputing that there may well be uh
serious you know climate change isn't a
real thing but the notion that humans
that we as humans you know by you know
dry years by you know driving electric
cars instead of petrol cars are going to
stop that is is insane
it just it's insane to me yeah it is and
you know i must tell you i don't think
you know when i hear the solutions that
are being offered by those who claim to
be in the know i'm unimpressed that they
know nearly i mean it's it's rather like
the cobit response i just don't believe
these people understand the problem well
enough to address it that said
you know if it were me
i would have my foot on the gas with
respect to fusion power because with
fusion power we do begin to get a you
can take an electric world you can plug
it into fusion so if we build an
electric world ahead of time right it
doesn't save the world but if you then
discover viable fusion technology you
can plug your electric world into the
fusion technology that does make a huge
dent
and also
with fusion you can pull carbon out of
the atmosphere if that's what you need
to do right nothing else is going to
provide enough power for us to do that
so
from my perspective you know it's it's
like we repurpose drugs and covet right
the right solution is just not on
anybody's tongue right or you know those
few who are
are heretics and so that tells me the
whole system is uh corrupt and putting
us in danger by
at the very least running out the clock
[Music]